Bitcoin now
contango
okay Kango you know currencies are cash
settled product okay
so you
currencies
trade very different from a lot of other
contracts because there's a lot of
obviously ARB um I don't know what the
percentage of ARB is now in against the
Futures in there but um you know it's
quite high and it's settled so it's it's
got a different makeup of participants
you know the the even though there
there's a lot of there is retail
participants it's not the percentage is
not as much as a lot of other markets so
um it's up to you if you want to use the
swing filter but I would turn off
contango for currencies all right so
let's just pull up
um what's my charts here
uh well let's P British P since that's
at the top of the list
so we'll start with
uh
settings okay so I'll turn off
contango and I I'll just leave the swing
filter disabled okay so it's not enabled
so it's showing anytime the flow
strength is appearing at five now again
you don't have to use five right you
could use three if if you're really if
you're trading on a dome or you know on
a contract maybe you just want to use
one or two I wouldn't use one honestly
I'd use um two or three if I was trading
down a dome and just looking for the
next few ticks um but okay so this is
British pound okay so this is showing
signals at every any time the condition
is met right if you're
trading
um basically momentum right if you're
trading against a dome or something you
want to know every time it's it's you
know there's some nice moves here right
in the currencies
but if you want to use a swing filter
you you can um you know if you say oh
mik you know that that's too many
signals I'm getting
confused put on a swing filter you it
could be five it could be one even right
so you saw how it looked before right
there were a bunch of buys and sells now
here you got this nice clean buy this
nice sell doesn't work and this nice buy
that works um you know you just got the
one cell signal up here whereas before
you had a few cell signals up there and
even on the way down um you know what
else during the day nice clean buy
there um let's go look at some of the
other days day before this 17th you know
you got that one signal here late in the
day you know getting short somewhere in
here 10 you know this is signal bars I
mean I have the trade entry signal on
so this is the actual trade bar is
telling you to get short somewhere as
soon as you start moving in this bar so
you know anywhere between 10 and 15 you
know say you get short at the very low
at 09 right down into
the down down down um there was a
buy you know here's
some buys but those are at the high of
the day
um again you know here was a nice Buy in
here honestly with currencies I don't
really get involved you know after 2:00
most contracts except the e- minis
Minis and micros you know you can trade
up to 3:00 but a lot of these markets
sort of follow the the know liquidity
really dries up after 2 o'clock this the
old floor
hours here's a couple Sals that did
nothing this is British pound um let's
take a look at Euro
currency again same settings you know
contango has turned off This is Swing
filters
on um you know here's a sell there's a
buy that doesn't work uh
there's no signals there now again if
you're like Mike why do I got signals in
the I had signals at night but during
the day um you see here there's nothing
well the swing filter might be too
strong for you either that or sorry the
flow strength might be too strong in
this par in that particular market so
drop it down a level go to go to three
now granted I have the swing filter on
so it's only looking for signals at
swing highs or swing lows if I disable
that I might get more signals but you
see here right I lowered the strength so
whereas before there was not this buy
and not this sell by lowering the
strength from five to three even you
could go down to one right if you don't
get any signals drop it down to a lower
level you might your flow strength might
be too high if I go to one I expect to
see more signals
okay and I can see more signals right
see this buy the cell here when it was
at three it was just this buy and this
cell you know a little buy here a little
buy there but when you're at one you're
going to be expecting a lot of signals
one is more for people that are scalping
in a pure sense right it it's the the
basic um movement in order flow right in
the sense that it's going
from either neutral or from bearish to
bullish or
from uh excuse me
or from bullish to bearish okay now the
strength is going to adjust it you know
if you want to get you know a bit
stronger order flow in a direction again
one is the absolute lowest you know so
you can see here it was it was bearish
right on this move down you had signal
up here signal here but then at this low
of the day overnight it turned to
bullish right
then it would have you know had a nice
move you know if you make these charts a
little shorter you can see bearish
bearish bearish bearish bearish right on
the low but then it turned bullish right
and it went from bullish off this low at
70 69 and a half all the way up into
back up into the mid
80s again this is with it set at its
bare
minimum okay and again you know during
the day on Thursday in the euro
currency uh this was overnight 16 uh SE
date 17th
again this is set at the bare minimum if
if I were to turn off the swing filter I
think this chart would be covered in not
covered in signals but you you're going
to get a lot of signals right so this is
the bare the bearest setting one no
swing filter no
contango but again you can see right if
you're trading a dome and you're just
looking for the next few ticks maybe you
want to do that right to catch this well
this was after the FED announcement
let's take a look at sort of normal
conditions you know
prior okay you get long okay should I
get out no it's still bullish it's still
bullish it's still bullish it's still
bullish it's still bullish you could
write it further still bull now it's
bearish right okay you get short okay
but still bearish still bearish still
bearish okay got my bullish signal I can
cover like that right Still bearish
Still bearish Still bearish again it's
it's pretty flexible you know on how you
want to use it right bearish bearish
bearish bearish bearish all this way
down if I was using a swing filter I
wouldn't have all the these but this is
the Bas the lowest setting you can use
right this why it's called the flow
scalper because it's it's really meant
to um initially was was based on my
trading in in markets where I'm just
looking for the next few ticks but you
know as we were programming it and I was
giving my input you know I said you know
actually it's can be used you know on
longer time frames um you know as well
if you are willing to you know adjust
the setting
Etc so you know on Range based charts I
would use a swing filter even if it's
just at Taiwan on volatile markets
obviously n NQ Dax I would use um swing
filter of of five pretty strong now one
minute is obviously shorter than a f
minute
chart and because of this on a 5minute
chart you may want to see more signals
due to momentum as well as reversal so I
would remove the swing filter on longer
time frame
charts so using the zones again I
explained
that if you want to use them you can you
don't have to it it some people it
clutters up their charts they don't want
to they don't want to look at it so you
could disable it
um again it's really depending on on
your trading style right so this is
ultra bonds right this is with
it all right and you know the reason why
I would use it is if I'm scalping and
I'm asking myself do I want to stay in
the trade but I still see it's bearish
based on the zones yeah even though
there's no Buy Signal in the opposite
direction um I would still keep it now
if I was long and I got a bearish signal
okay that's where I got to pay attention
to the market right that's where I got
to trade that's where you gotta earn
your money as a
Trader right sort of in here right if
you're short from up here you can see
bearish signal
still bearish Zone you know even though
you got a bullish Zone you okay well let
me see is is it going to start moving up
or not you know if I had a bullish Zone
come in here then a bullish Buy Signal
obviously i' have to get out but if it's
just okay maybe it's just short covering
right we had this move down right this
is gold she had this move down a little
bounce little short covering some
bullish order flow Then followed by
bearish bearish you know okay now it's
turned bearish okay it's coming up I
still want to be short yep still want to
be short still want to be short short
all the way
down
so
that's it um it's gone an hour and a
half I I want to go through some of
these questions in here um because it's
a bit a bit longer again
for a lot of people um you know I'm
I'm trying to get together with Pablo to
do a joint training session joint
webinar on markers and
and um and the flow
scalper you know so you can have a a
template that that works with it said
you know markers is is a great tool for
getting you into the trades you know it
can be used for auto trading um he's got
a lot of nice little features in there
is that you hit a certain loss for the
day it stops trading or you s Hur
certain profit for the day it also
stopped trading but I like to use it to
get into the trades um because you know
sometimes you know you do get distracted
you're looking at a couple different
markets and you know someone talks to
your phone rings or whatever you got a
message you know you just look at your
phone and boom you just missed your
trade entry um it's it's great tool for
that so I I do want to spend some time
up this weekend I'll probably put out a
video on markers myself um outside of
working with Pablo so I'm just going to
go through uh some of these questions
here real quick said um do you charge
for White Glove installation honestly in
installation is very easy right all you
do is you just uh you go to Ninja Trader
control panel right once you have Ninja
Trader
up
um once you have Ninja Trader up or you
download the indicator through your hard
drive you just click on import you click
on ADD ninjas script add-on um it's
going to pop up a
box where's my box it's on another
screen here so here right downloads you
just click on that click
open and then it'll when it's done it'll
say it's successfully installed and then
obviously when you go to open a new
chart say for the first time all you got
to do right you just click here you tick
uh what's Point figure change that to
minute make sure you have tick replay
enabled you just open up your chart
whatever chart you
want I'll just use the default chart
which is black I prefer white um Some
people prefer black right so it's there
then you just add it you go to your
indicators and you just find it in here
right you click on it double click so it
appears down here you enter your license
token click
apply okay but you got to make sure you
have tick replay enabled if you don't
have tick replay enabled um it's not
going to show on the historical chart um
is it based on imbalances are there
settings for it upload it's different
because someone ask you know is it the
same as orderflow Trader 3.0
um Don yeah Don you can you
have orderflows Trader 2 let me just
write this down here so I I I know to
send you an email you should have gotten
an email over the last couple months
anybody that's got the orderflows
trader like 2.0 or even there's some
people that still actually use NT uh
nt7 um when we moved to nt8 a few years
ago with
with uh what do you call it Ninja Trader
with the orderflows we released the
orderflows trader 2.0 which was the
first version for nt8 but just a few
months ago we released
uh the order FL trator 3.0 for nt8 which
has got a lot more tools um on it it has
the same tools but we've added a few
more tools that make it a lot easier to
read but I'll send you the email or you
could just drop me an email and I'll
reply to it the email the uh upgrade for
n for orful Trader 3.0 the footprint
chart is free for existing users of
orderflows Trader now um let's see are
signals on the
bar are the signal at the open of the
bar or close of the bar well it occur if
it depends right there's two types of
signals if you're not using the trade
entry signal it'll appear on the signal
bar as soon as it happens okay
um but again you know the bar is still
open in the sense that the bar is still
Trading you're looking at a one minute
bar it's got to complete one minute
before the bar closes so you could have
a
signal in the bar if you're just if
you're not using the trade entry signal
so if the bar is still trading
conditions can be bullish and you get a
bullish signal but then it turns bearish
the second half and it wipes it out the
signal disappears but once the bar
closes that's it it's not going to re if
there's a signal it will stay there
forever if there's no signal it won't
appear okay if you're using the trade
entry signal meaning the bar the
orderflow has to be conducive over the
next two bars and move a certain amount
of ticks then it won't appear on the
signal bar it'll appear on the bar where
the order flow confirms it and once
that's there that's there whether it
moves up by two ticks you get the signal
and then it drops 100 ticks you'll still
have that signal there that will not
repaint
ever
um is orderflow combining the tools from
orderflows Trader 3.0 no it it's not
sort of the the tools in orderflows
Trader
3.0 are more specific
on the order flow um whereas in the
sense of you know you still got to read
the order flow okay you still got to put
sort of the pieces together but sort of
the new things that we have in
orderflows Trader 3.0 such as the value
area inverse and balances are not part
of this uh software
um yeah the signals are exposed the
sense that like software like as markers
can use it um because the question
is actually I should put these I don't
want to put the questions on on the main
screen because if I do then you know
everyone's names will be exposed um but
question is are
signals signals exposed so Blood Hound
can see them well they I said I don't
use Blood Hound I use markers markers
can see them Blood Hound again I have
some users that use other indicators of
mine that do use it with blood hound
um signals need to be entered manually
no auto trading again you can set it up
with auto trading software such as
markers um so I you know I I help I
don't say I help Pablo but I I talk a
lot about markers in the sense that you
it's a tool that I like I use I don't
get any Kickback from even from poo
although I wish he would give me some of
his software for free but you I pay for
everything like marker
um other tools um but uh you know again
I don't say it because you know he's
paying me back you know in whatever he
sells I say because I like it right it's
good
um can I access the triangles in a
strategy
programmatically yes I just answered
that can you use it to trade pullbacks
or to just scalp yeah you could use it
for for both um and swings um or
scalping yes tick re question is is
replay required to be enabled yes it is
um signals show up immediately or
repainted I sort of went over that
question already um as a bar is forming
conditions can be met and then unmet all
right so the signal can appear then
disappear but once the bar is closed
once the bar is finished it's there okay
and if you're using the trade entry
signal even though the conditions are
met in the signal bar and
then the order flow over the next couple
bars moves in that direction the signal
is there even if it reverses in that bar
it's still there um are the symbols
chart markers
yes they
are
um's these questions
um what's the exit strategy see buy and
sell signals well again that depends on
your your trading you know in a lot of
Auto Traders I said I trade manually I
don't sit and forget things I don't just
turn on an auto markers and just leave
it there and go to bed um I love the
market right I been involved in the
markets for a long time 25 years and
over 25 years and it's
uh I always have my my computers on um I
don't trade in the sense where I could
just let something run automatically
like that honestly I've got kids they do
come into my office off take paper for
their drawings and stuff and sometimes I
go in there I see my screen messed up
with something like touching my screen
so I don't want to leave it on I trade
um I I let this I will turn markers on
let it get into trades and then I'll
manage it from there yes there will be a
recorded video coming out um question is
will you be sending out recorded video
yes I will um ranco bars
no it I I don't use wrco bars
and I don't think you can even plot
historical data on Rinko bars I don't
think the tick replay even works on
Rinko bars um because you do need tick
replay enabled what the swing period
signif signify well it it signifies
the
um you know if the market is is putting
in new highs or new lows over a certain
period of time so contango it's question
about contango
go okay well here question is do you
have a list of settings that you would
recommend for different instruments with
different types of charts or we should
just play with it well I showed you two
basic settings based on markets that are
volatile right and markets that just
trade they're not as volatile just trade
sort of normally right the the normal
function of the market to facilitate
trade so on more volatile markets you
know I'm going to use a swing fil
because there's a lot of noise so to
speak in the market there's a lot of up
down up down up down in those volatile
markets whereas markets that are sort of
trade just sort of regularly
um you you don't have that noise so you
know I was showing you is five Zer is
the swing filter you don't necessarily
need a swing filter unless you really
want to filter out trades um five as the
flow strength and and one as the
contango strength um because that sort
of
leads into the next question is do
so e- minis would not need Kango well
you don't necessarily need it in the e-
minis but you you I find it's it gives
you a few
extra um extra signals that you know you
might not necessarily need because you
know e- minis is again it's one of those
contracts even though it's cash
settled there's a lot of commercial
players in there as well um so yeah I
would use Kango in E minis but I i' set
it at one you don't need to set it as
five you don't need to set Kango at the
same contango strength at the same
strength as you
would um the normal flow strength the
main setting you got to mess around with
I say mess around but you know um get
used to in your Market is the flow
strength the normal flow strength okay
and then next would be the swing period
if you're going to use a swing or not
and what period you want to use and then
last one would be contango
yes signals
uh stay up all day long can you use it
on more than one chart meaning one
minute and five minute together uh yeah
that depends how you trade me personally
I I look at one chart I trade that one
chart I don't trade you know five minute
against one minute although I do
monitor um you know if I'm trading a one
minute chart I I do look at what is
happening on on a f minute chart if it's
you know if I'm if it's bearish is the
market it's still going down
Etc
um this is a lot of stuff to remember do
you have a recording of This yes there
will be a recording did you list the
settings for different instruments yeah
roughly um yeah I do have one there I
showed you
earlier and again it's going to be in
this recording and again you know it's
the problem with putting out a list is
sometimes you know people think it's set
in stone right oh Mike says you have to
use
in this market on this time frame on
this chart you have to use this setting
no right that's what I recommend based
on what I would use for that market
right maybe I don't you look at natat
gas I do look at n gas but you know I
don't trade it and somebody comes up to
me I'm a n gas Trader what settings
should I use well this is you know I'll
take a look at it I'll start with my
basic settings that I use for all
markets because you know you don't want
to start getting into really
finessing um the settings right a good
tool especially if you're reading order
flow order flow basically follows every
you know whether you're trading the
markets whether you're trading crypto or
you're trading cars or beanie babies or
whatever you know it's the buying and
selling that's going on in the world
that's affecting the market so you know
you could adjust the settings but you
you shouldn't have to like try and curve
fit it all um but you know yeah I do
have you know start with the general
settings you know and I had a list there
and again it'll be in this recording
I'll probably make a PDF of this
this uh presentation as well that you
can download which I'll I'll throw in
the email a link that you can download
it when I get it out
later um is it useful used it with the
pulse or turn signals again it's it's a
different indicator um it reads
different things in the
orderflow uh does it work well on tick
charts yes you can use it with tick
charts if I load the indicator and look
at last week's charts are the signals
accurate do you have to run Live Well
yeah the signals you know you could open
your chart up 10 times it'll still be
the same signals um you have to run Live
Well if you're using tick replay you can
see last week's signals
um and if you're running live then
you're
fine uh how far ahead on the trade entry
signal can we set there there's settings
on there you don't have to go beyond I
use two and two the max you go is five
on either of them
you don't want to wait you get a signal
in the order flow you don't want to wait
um you know if you're on a minute based
chart you don't want to set the trade
entry signal to to to 10 you know you're
waiting 10 minutes for the market to
move based on what's happening right now
because in the meantime there could be
something else coming into the market
that
uh that is opposite to what you know
gave you the signal in the first place
so that's why I keep it within the next
couple of
bars and and uh next amount of ticks you
know again if if you're on a volatile
Market you know maybe you want to set it
to three I
I I I played with five on very volatile
market like NASDAQ you know back earlier
in the year when the markets were really
berserk um back in April in
March but uh two is fine you
know um how well would Paul ask about
blood hound I again I don't use Blood
Hound other people do on other
indicators of mine and they say it works
I don't know I honestly I don't know I
don't use Blood Hound how well would
this work on a commodity like Lumber hly
I haven't looked at Lumber since I was
on the floor I haven't I've looked at a
chart but I haven't looked at a
footprint um you know the old
you one of my favorite stories when I
was on the trading this is sort of an
aside is I was a runner when I first
started out on the CM floor I ran you
start out as a runner just basically as
the lowest life form on on the CM me is
you're running orders to the trading pit
and I ran an order and like an idiot I'm
holding it up to the broker so he can
read it but then these guys in the pit
broker was wood that was his badge
number name wood the guys in the pit are
looking through the paper to see what
the order was you know sort of pick it
off but anyway that's sort of an aside
honestly I haven't looked at Lumber I'm
sure it uh would honestly I'm kind of
curious let's take a look at Lumber
anyway while it's here um
uh random length Lumber I don't even
know what month
is going on here so what do I got let's
take a look at the
settings well yeah you probably don't
want to use
contango this is what they set at the
slowest level settings no not
really no I I'd say Lumber is probably
not a market you want to use this
with but again I don't think many people
trade Lumber based on uh based on what
I'm seeing here in the order flow if I
I'm kind of curious what the footprint
looks like on Lumber yeah there's just
not enough flow going on in in Lumber um
at least on a one minute chart
if maybe on
a I don't know if even five minutes
would be good enough on
Lumber yeah
I would stay away from Lumber in general
you know that sort of been my experience
with Lumber since I was on the trading
floor um it's it's a it's a market that
in my experience has always been
controlled by a a select few at least
when I was on the floor you know we used
to joke um because the guys on the pit
would be like okay you because it's all
like a family business you know it's
like my brother-in-law and you know my
cousin you know they're all the locals
in the PIN to be like okay everybody
Market opens everybody short okay limit
down you like that but uh what's the
minimum data for the chart one day three
days again it's up to you I I think I
use five is my setting um but you can
adjust it you can go back as as long as
you have the tick data you can go back
how many days needed that's sort of how
many days of data needed for one minute
chart you can start at zero you know but
if you want to look at past data you can
go back you know as long you have the
data you can go back
weeks um bam do you back test yes we
back test do you ever set it on
autopilot I said on entry on autopilot I
don't let it take me out on autopilot
unless the market moves so fast it just
either stops me out immediately or or
hits my profit Target which sometimes
you know these markets they do
that um any he talks about how clients
back test well you know everyone sort of
does it their own they they share the
results with me but again you know
that's the private thing um are the
signals exposed so they can be read by
shark yep I've answered that one Derek
can I split payments honestly we we try
to if you want to split payments email
me and we'll discuss it I I have an
introductory price right now till for
the time being where it's it's pretty
low um but eventually it's going to go
up cuz uh we're launching this big over
in in another
Market but I want you know my my users
to get a good deal on it so on the
signals on L I was just curious why not
showing all major swing highs or low uh
so the question is on signals on last
chart is curious why signal not showing
up on all major swing high or low is
because that would chart was
probably
um not the the swings were probably not
set it was probably showing a swing
filter was probably
off because if you have a swing filter
are set to five if it's the high of the
day which would be your swing High
obviously it will it will still show
there um question is I purchased the
orderflows course back in August to I
have to pay for this flow scul yeah this
is a separate indicator it's not
included in the orderflow
course and both next to uh see go
through some more questions how many
days data are you
loading again I I s answered that
earlier you could load as many as you
want what is the minimum well minimum
you can start at zero but you know I I
suggest at least the last day or two can
you see crude oil I showed crude oil um
so the signals appearing are on close of
bar um yeah I explained that again it's
the signals will appear if you're using
trade entry signal it'll
appear within the next couple of bars
and if the bar is still alive if you're
not using trade entry signal if the
order flow conditions are met the signal
will appear but it can change until the
bar finishes okay because the order flow
can change as the bar is still trading
back and forth but once the bar is
closed that's it they will not uh
repaint um would you run two charts one
with swing one with
filth um question is would you run two
charts one with swing on and one with
swing off for better confirmation or the
trade St a trade longer yeah you you can
um honestly you I'm so used to looking
at how the markets swing so to speak
that
uh I'm I'm just used to it again I'm
always looking to be buying at um lows
swing lows or selling at swing highs I'm
I'm just training to do that
now do you use an ATM yeah well
with um you know that's just one of the
nice features in most Trading
systems now is you got to use an ATM
period whether you're trading manually
or whether you're trading Auto um as
soon as your trade gets in you got to
put in a stop you know especially you
know these markets at volatile times you
could get stopped out 10 seconds
afterwards or you could hit your
takeprofit 10 seconds afterwards and the
market reverses
so um yeah you'd want to do that uh a
minute or 10- minute
chart a minute or a 10-minute chart
would sometimes produce same signals as
swing trade
signals they can you know it can it's uh
no guarantee you know obviously
conditions are going to be different if
you're looking at a one minute chart
versus a 10-minute chart Ultra bonds
fris my favorite Market yeah it's a nice
market for a lot of people Dax can you
show Dax yes I
did where do you have your stop and
Target again you know I prefer to read
the order flow once I'm in the trade um
I do have e- minis you know when when
you're setting stops and
targets initial stops and take profits
on your ATM understand the market
rotations and what the levels are right
like e- minis is about four and a half
points so that's what I have my my stop
in and my takeprofit in so you know 16
and 16 I think that is it's uh it's just
what I have programmed in there so
that's four points on either side and
then I'll adjust it accordingly you know
if I see the market going nowhere then
I'll just move my stop up or maybe move
my take profit down or or just get out
you know I I I'm an order flow Trader I
I read the order flow I don't use
stochastics question is do stochastics
or macd work to confirm entries I don't
know I haven't looked at stochastics or
macd since
um can you show quickly es32 chart
on
um Mike can you show quickly e mini 30
second chart and Ultra Bond 4 range
chart yeah let me
just okay well first I'll put
a what was the one e
minis let's go here to e minis real
quick
let's give it a second
here I forgot what settings I'm using
here on this chart I think this set
pretty low um again I I would use on a
30 second
chart if you're tra a 30 second chart
you're probably looking to trade some
momentum um so I'd probably keep this
off swing filter off I would start at
five I would keep definitely canang go
there and go from
there so this is 05 and one okay so just
give it a second to come up then I'll
take a look at Ultra Bond um preferably
also without the trade entry signal yeah
um again this is a 302 e mini
chart you know if you're scalping you're
looking to get in and out you know if
you're on a 30 second chart you're
you're looking to trade a lot during the
day um so you're just you you're going
to be using rotations for your stops and
and take profits this was Friday
during the US session this was the Cash
open
here this is prior to Cash open this was
the evening
session go back you know even the Asian
session was at
21 it's not 9 o'clock Chicago time you
know again that nice move up off that
low to the swing
high and again I would use this sort of
you know you're in this position right
your R Market's going up going up should
I get out here sort of coming into this
area where there was some selling
earlier well you know what the order
flow is still bullish based on this
here you know the day
before is a little bit the Thursday was
kind of
choppy but you know there was some
trades to be had some moves to be had
death by a Thousand Cuts on choppy days
but again if you trading with um the
swing filter off you know it could help
you stay trades a little longer
right because you're seeing the the conf
the confirming order flow
happening right that's the day before
again some nice nice move down going
into the uh weekly nonfarm with the
weekly uh number jobs number but earlier
than that again some decent moves night
session again some decent moves off this
High Ultra Bond four range
charts where's Ultra
bones just really quick
here so this is ultra bonds again if
you're Ultra bonds is great Market
scalping so this is with the swing
filter turned
off swing filter turned
on again really cleaned it up you see
this sell here this buy did nothing
these sells would get stopped out then
you again cat this nice move say well I
got stopped out stopped out here well
this move here from starting at night at
24 21 uh sorry 22 24 down to 211 24
that's a full point right there another
full point here so why Ultra bonds why
people love these Ultra bonds
is if you could catch a move you know
like that it's it's a powerful move you
know this previous this day here it's
kind
of if you don't have the
uh
whoops swing filter
on again it's up to you if you want to
use it or not or you could even set it
to one I'll show you so This is Swing
filter turned off right you could caught
this big monster move almost a two-point
move
down another thing you might want to do
is set it a little little closer one
swing filter of
one again I did that pretty fast but if
you have swing filter set to one right
one you know you could
catch more moves it's it's I say it's
one tick better than having it turned
off but um it's going to give you a
little bit of the minor swings you know
which is you know some nice things here
in the ultra bonds um how many days of
day you're loading um again it's up to
you I load and whenever I load a chart I
always start with
three um great webinar what's the best
email contact to you Mike at orderflows
um yeah Phil asks about Forex
spots you can use you know what what
people do in in China actually is they
they use the data from the CME and then
they just trade the Forex spot Market
you know the euro currency or the uh
pound you know they use you know the 6C
the the 6B 6j um on their
chart because the data is better it's
centralized whereas Forex data is not so
it's uh then they just execute you know
on their Forex Accounts at at wherever
so that's that's you know I don't like
using Forex data but uh can just because
the data is kind of crap comes from
everywhere
yes this again is is recorded being
recorded yes it
is um
Jerry is there any special deals yeah
right now I got the special deal that is
the special deal uh when you go to when
you go here
because later it's going to go up
um are there limited market orders well
it depends on how you you
trade again about shark indicators um
yeah you can can can I use it on any one
of three pcs one at a time well ninja
Trader the way the licensing works with
our indicators is is they linked to a
certain machine ID right and if you have
three PCS each PC has a different
machine ID from Ninja
Trader so it require three IDs um three
license tokens so You' need literally
three copies um we are going to you know
for people that are in that situation
that want to have it on more than one
piece see email me uh we do have special
deals for that price does not include
two machines it is for one
machine
but again if you if you require more
than one license um email me and tell me
how many licenses you need and we'll put
together a special
offer can you use it as a standalone yes
you can use it as Standalone if you
don't use order flow at all if you just
look at normal bar charts which I was I
purposely showed just bar charts on here
you can do that you could also use it on
an footprint chart I use it on a
footprint chart but a lot of people
haven't made that transition to using
full-fledged order flow no there's no
trial period the question is is there a
trial period no there's not
um I I don't offer trials anymore um
because you know I want people that are
serious about their trading rather than
just shiny object syndrome oh here's a
new indicator it looks good I'm GNA buy
it then just return it it's you know I I
I really go through a lot of charts and
show you guys a lot of charts I'm doing
this webinar so you could hopefully
understand you know is this if for you
and you know and your type of trading
and the markets that you
trade um John
Dave I would like to add my own custom
NT script to flow scalper do you have a
programmer do you recommend you shoot me
an email I'm not going to I'll answer it
there because I do have programmers that
I work
with markers question is what is markers
is it's a uh trade entry
software trade automation software I
guess is a better term is there a demo
trial version no there's not um do you
have a use n or do you have to use nt8
for full scaer or work with nt7 no only
nt8 we do not support nt7 on this it was
never we've never programmed it for
nt7 I don't I haven't used nt7 since I
think
uh February of
2018 and uh can you please show es or NQ
yes I did
um yes you could run it on a tick chart
can it be run on a tick chart
yes uh
Bonnie yeah Bonnie I'll take a look at
your email um again it's uh the upgrade
is free for orderflows Trader
3.0 um but I'll send it out to you will
it work on a 30 second
chart yes it will I just showed you um e
min's 30 second chart um
vam I'm not sure of your question do you
expose signal data series publicly that
can be accessed by external
strategy I'm not sure that question um
I'm not a tech guy I'm not a programmer
um so I can't ask that but again it does
work with other um systems in the sense
that uh you could add it to markers and
it'll read
signals does Delta scalper function
similar to flow scalper no it doesn't
it's uh completely different
John asks what do I have to do to have
the signal stay on all
day they will all stay on all day you
don't have to do
anything vom ask uh do you use other
levels like daily volume profile trend
lines
pivots open range and conduction with
order flow um yeah I do actually that
yeah that's a whole another training
session
um Paul do I have a trading room no I I
don't I don't have a trading room
um yeah if another question is are
updates free yeah the updates are free
um usually the the individual indicators
um we don't do many upgrades on them but
um like our regular software if we did
it would be free it send you an email
and all you got to do is just download
it and install
it Gord are you you using this indicator
do you turn anything on in Trader Gord
I'm not sure of that
question um maybe you can clarify that
in an email to me I did you answer the
question number of days did you answer
the question on the number of days of
data need to load again you can start at
zero if if you just want to use it going
forward or you could load like one day
two days 3 days honestly I don't there's
really not a need to load more than 5
days of data unless you really want to
do you know more in-depth um
system
um is this a standalone system yeah it's
it's a stand alone in the sense that you
know you don't need to use order flow
with
it but I like to I use order flow to
manage my trades um so it's uh it's up
to
you um second license James asked about
a second license yeah I'll send you an
email on
that um Jerry left but yeah just send me
an email you know Jerry's left but when
you watch the replay Jerry you're asking
about the third licenses Etc uh just let
me know shoot me an email as usual and
I'll get back to you on
that Brian what's the best indicator to
trade pullback in direction of trend on
one minute
chart
um well again that's the whole style of
trading you know I've got a couple weeks
off usually I take the last two weeks of
the year off
um catch up on things and and one of the
things I wanted I plan on doing
is uh you know make some more videos on
on different ways of of trading it you
know obviously pullbacks is the way a
lot of people trade and um I want to
talk about that but again that's going
to be another
presentation um NES is asking about
discounts for two or three indicat
package deal yeah shoot me an email on
on what exactly you're looking for um
and we'll get to uh we'll get to that
and Bonnie yeah I'll take a look at your
your email and your
um your upgrade make a note here Bonnie
upgrade
from orderflows Trader 2.0 to 3.0 2.0
because I got also check your license so
it might take
me
um I'll get it def to you this afternoon
um John you got to send me
a screenshot of your settings
um
okay and send me a screen and make sure
you got tick data enabled because it
sort of sounds like if if you don't have
tick daa data enabled when you open a
chart and then the chart is running it's
going to from the time the moment you
open a chart and it's
running is getting the data from you
know your data source it's going to plot
okay but then you close everything down
and then today you open it up and you
see no
signals is your chart probably doesn't
have tick data enabled okay so just go
through that that steps um again is a
price listed a onetime fee or a monthly
Fe it's a onetime fee um it's again it's
it's you know a lot of people have this
model where they want recurring you know
payments coming in every month I I hate
that you know I I my kids buy these
things on the App Store sometimes I see
my charge card what's this $9.95 you
know my kid bought something that's just
recurring forever and sometimes these
things you try to cancel them it's such
a hassle you can't um that's why it's
just a one-time fee it's not a it's not
a monthly fee order flow Trad are these
trade indicators on order flow Trader
you still use it yeah I do um
it's for example I don't have it on that
uh footprint chart but uh
whoops long chart
uh get here my Ultra Bond chart so for
example you know I would on my other PC
um my trading PC yeah I have it added on
there right so it's going to signal to
me where the um you where it's occurring
all right then you know once I get into
the trade because I I run markers also
on the the orderflow
chart then it's going to um get me into
the trade then I manage it based on what
I'm seeing in the order
flow so yeah I'm still using it so you
know if I'm you know say I'm
uh I think I got this thing
turned everything off let me see if I
got another footprint in here like a
normal one um this is the Bulge but you
know say I'm
in a trade right and it's
well find some you know situation here
um you know is if I'm short you know
from somewhere in here whatever it's
hypothetical okay it's still going down
this a five minute chart and I see
something like this right the um
slingshot PC yeah I'd probably still
stay short Okay then if I'm still short
so if I'm short from I don't know 98
okay
and then it's just going sideways here
and I start seeing okay this is bullish
right overflow sequencing then I get up
here it's sort of right around my entry
point and I see another bullish thing
the PLC slingshot then I start thinking
okay well maybe I what am I going to do
am I going to hold this trade or not is
because this is a bullish sign to me
right I had a bullish signal here maybe
I got out already here at 95 if I'm not
out I got a bullish signal here I'm
going to watch you know I maybe I'll
move my stop down to just
um you know right above this area here
because if this next bar starts shooting
up you know it could pop 10 points on me
so I'll still watch the order flow um
what's your setting for trading for KL
heyy Jason
um where's my KL chart uh you know they
got this the new contract in KL they
just relaunched that uh micro is crap
um the fm70 but uh let me just find my
KL
chart
uh here it's swing filter off 10 for
the volume um
five contango turned off
um since this interesting question um
show you palm
oil pal oil is a nice contract
um that's it that the two what do
I might be a little confusing with all
these these signals but you know palm
oil is also a nice I love palm oil
I move a lot through it in palm oil I've
it's uh I spent a lot of time trading
palm oil um over the years
professionally pal is also a nice
contract to trade you can catch some big
moves KL is pretty quiet most of the
time but obviously the last few days
have been really big moves in the Market
Palm is also a nice contract to trade um
but again that's uh only for us you know
very for few people you're one of the
the few people I've met that have asked
me about those markets outside of you
know people that work as uh in commodity
trading firms so it's nice um
some
say volume is the key early and proper
entries does flose scop reflect volume
based moves yeah it does it does take
into account volume um you know volume
is very important right because not all
prices are equal in how they trade um
you know that's the big difference
between an indicator and an orderflow
indicators normal indicators don't even
look at volume they just look at Price
they're price Centric and basically
they're just taking the math and and
trying to
manipulate price but you know without
volume you're you're really left uh
behind Brian just asked real quick
there's a couple more questions here
then we'll be done how to turn on tick
replay all right so I'll just show you
this real quick so here right when you
try to load a chart okay anything right
you'll see there's tick replay right you
got to click that when you open a chart
right then you click okay if you don't
have this thing that says tick replay
okay show you got to go to tools go to
Options under Market data show Tick
replay okay gotta make sure that's
ticked because if it's not ticked okay
this is what it's going to look
like chart uh right I'll go to open the
chart you'll see there's no function
here for tick replay right you have to
have it turned on you have to have it
enabled so go to Tool
tools
options Market
data cck
replay click apply click
okay click
chart and you'll see when you open the
chart click uh tick replay now I don't
know about you guys but
um okay so then we'll open the chart
here so if you know so this is your
normal black screen when I open charts I
don't go through that whole process I
just duplicate the chart know so for
example let me just get my regular chart
here
uh here all right
so okay so this is my normal chart here
right I don't go through that I just
duplicate the chart I just click on here
duplicate chart in a new tab just so it
just shows up in the bottom down here
it's going to have all my settings so if
you have tick play already open then
it's going to show up in there okay um
and then I just go in and I CH you know
if I want to mess around with the
settings or add another indicator on a
chart or something that's how I do it um
rather than going through that whole
control panel thing and opening a
chart um all right
so I think that's about it James
asks uh
you know James asked about the classes
that help interpret Market data
psychology um you
know because he talks about how he's in
uh he's finishing up uh his
NBA and you still got some money left on
your GI Bill yeah you know what Market
psychology you know honestly these
economics professors nowadays
is kind it's kind of stale um you know I
I don't I was fortunate you know like I
said I went to school in Chicago and I
had a course on um on Futures actually
my my teacher was a member of The
Exchange and you know we even had
contest in class about Futures Trading
but honestly um psychology right just
you know how people think because you
know basically you're trading against
other other Traders you're not trading
against the market right you're trading
against what other people are doing in
the market
at at any point in time so there's
there's a lot of psychology honestly I
read and you know take a step further
sports psychology if you could find a
class on sports psychology it's not
going to help you think sports
psychology will help you think
internally right because Athletics and
trading has a lot of overlap um in the
way Traders think and the way athletes
think and prepare and um you basically
live their life so so it's it's a
fascinating subject I mean plain
psychology might be a little just
general psychology might be a little
boring but you know if you can find like
a sports psychology thing even one or
two classes you might find it very
fascinating um any times I get you know
I get a book on on sports psychology I
just find it fascinating reading know
how these Olympic athletes uh spend
their lives you know even professional
athletes
um you know their mindset right that
that's going to help you out just in
life in general I think on on being
successful so anyway guys um it kind of
over almost two and a half hours wow
it's uh it's been great thanks um again
you know don't be shy and sending me an
email a question I hope I was able to
get to everybody's questions if if I
didn't I um you got any other further
questions just shoot me an email yes
this is uh recorded
and I'll get it out to
everybody so
just uh you know hopefully
uh
um you know you you can do uh you you
can do some you have a nice Christmas
and again you know this not time to be
trading it's the end of the year get
ready for next year you know the markets
are going to you know even though it
looks bleak sometimes you know like you
know people are even though the market's
at all-time highs
um it's the end of the year Market's
going to be choppy going to be volatile
so just uh you know now is not a time to
be trading and you have a loss and it's
going to affect your Christmas forget it
you know enjoy the time with your family
um and uh Merry Christmas everybody and
uh hope to hear from you soon in the
again any questions shoot me an email
but uh you know for those in my weekly
sessions I I'll see you guys back in uh
January January 5th for our weekly
session so have a great holiday and
again thanks for your time today again
it's it was a long session
so have a great uh have a great rest of
the weekend and a great holiday
bye-bye e